[Music]
I'm pleased to welcome to the platform
this morning
the Honorable Alice K Wolfe mayor of the
city of Cambridge it is my privilege now
to welcome to this lectern dr. Walter E
Massey director of the National Science
Foundation dr. Massey will give the
address
thank you very much president vest
professor great members of the faculty
above all the class of 1991 and then
also to who I'm sure the most happy
people on this occasion the parents of
the class of 1991 I'm very pleased to be
part of this occasion I want to
congratulate you especially it's an
honor to be asked to give the
commencement address at MIT I've
attended a number of ceremonies and I've
heard over the years some students that
perhaps the greatest achievement on this
day is simply to survive the
commencement exercises as much fun and
it's much of an honor as it is it can be
quite a challenge to you I hope to help
you survive at them by keeping my
remarks brief
well kind of brief well you will survive
because each of you have already proven
that you have the intelligence and
wherewithal to master one of the most
rigorous academic programs in the nation
so you can surely master these
commencement exercises now I don't know
if the following story is true but a
colleague of mine at Harvard told me
that grade point averages at MIT are
carried out to the third decimal place
when I expressed surprise he suggested
that only MIT and God are able to
distinguish excellence with such
precision when you leave here you will
be joining an elite corps of graduates
from the nation's premier research
universities for decades mit has been a
leading site for advances in basic
understanding and innovation in science
and engineering advances that are the
foundation for continuing prosperity and
for an improved quality of life and as
such MIT is a precious resource and a
valued institution to more than its
students more than its graduates and
more than those directly involved in its
operation this university and others of
its kind play a critical role in setting
and sustaining the high standards of
achievement in research and technology
as graduates of MIT you have assumed a
duty to uphold this tradition of
excellence in all your pursuits what
does this mean and how do you go about
it excellence is a quality that is
recognized by comparison
while it is judged generally from
without excellence begins within
individuals achieve excellence through
the choices and decisions they make
regarding the conduct of their lives
this is true in all endeavors but it is
especially true in an area of keen
interest to me and to most of you that
is the area of research in science and
engineering research can be thought of
and many do think of it as a cut in
dried process and it is true that there
are some rules of the game but to
paraphrase my good friend Nobel laureate
Leon Cooper he wrote that the object of
research is discovering how the world
works separating the truth about the way
things are from conceptions of the way
they might be and to accomplish this
task
good good researchers have several
qualities good researchers are skeptical
they evaluate claims empirically and
logical not on the basis of Authority
good researchers are open sharing their
hypotheses methodologies and results and
making their primary data available to
others and they do this so that results
can be reproduced and findings confirmed
and this way the research community
protects its interest in the truth good
science engineering and scholarship in
all fields in fact is an uncompromising
pursuit of truth and as such it
represents one of the highest
achievements of human intelligence and
provides a constant source of enrichment
to humankind's existence intellectually
spiritually and materially as chemists
call gerace's notes on a recent novel
called Cantor's dilemma dilemma he says
in science there can be no perfect crime
and no permanently unsolved murder in
the quote because if a finding is
important sooner or later the experiment
will be repeated the results subjected
to experimental verification the rules
of research keep science and engineering
and scholarship truthful simply put this
entire edifice of research is built upon
honesty and perhaps more than any other
endeavor individuals conducting
fundamental research depend upon the
veracity of the accumulated insights and
accomplishments of others Sir Isaac
Newton Newton expressed it best when he
said if I have seen further
it is by standing up on the shoulders of
giants but not even Giants can see
clearly if their feet are on shaky
ground few things are more damaging to
the research Enterprise than falsehoods
be they the result of error
self-deception sloppiness and haste or
in the worst case dishonesty and it is
the paradox of modern research that
reliance upon truth is both the source
of modern science and engineering
enduring excellence but also as part of
its intrinsic fragility so where do
young researchers first learn the rules
of the game that protect the integrity
of their endeavors for generations the
community has relied upon the unique
mentor apprentice relationship that
develops during the process of doctoral
post doctoral and undergraduate research
to teach these important lessons when
all goes well a bond of trust develops
between the professor and his or her
students which is grounded in
intellectual curiosity a desire to
discover new knowledge and a common
commitment to truth what is conveyed and
what is learned is more than simply a
body of facts it is an approach to
understanding an appreciation of
standards and a set of values in fact an
ethic I was very fortunate in my own
graduate training to have had a research
director from whom I learned a great
deal a great deal of physics and much
more besides professor Eugene Fein Berg
who's now deceased was a prominent
physicist well-respected among his peers
and a man of integrity and unyielding
honesty all of us who were his students
saw these traits in him and we profited
from working with him to come to class
Yale prepared or not to take time to
listen to his students and their
problems to publish a result prematurely
simply to gain priority or to put his
name on a paper by one of his students
when he had not done the
lion's share of the work himself all
these things were nassima to Jane
Feinberg those of our who were those of
us who were his students realized how
lucky we were to have had an almost
ideal mentor-student relationship but
most mentor student relationships are
not ideal most commencement surroundings
are not ideal
too often important lessons in
scientific integrity remain unlearned
for a number of reasons fundamental
changes in the way research is now
conducted in many fields not just in
physics but increase this possibility
more and more we are moving away from
small tightly knit research communities
in which misconduct is easily observed
towards large anonymous research
enterprises in which tasks are
fragmented and accountability is hard to
ascribe consider the experimental team
that did the work resulting in the 1984
Nobel Prize in Physics it consisted of
over a 150 people well what is it like
to be a student or postdoc in a group of
I'm sure it's exciting and important
definitely but it's unlikely to provide
the same opportunities for personal
interactions with a mentor that one has
in a smaller group in such circumstances
some important values may go unlearned
and key safeguards against misconduct
may be left undeveloped another fact is
that experimental replication which is a
major safeguard against research
improprieties is also more difficult now
reproducing experiments has always been
more of a problem in some fields such as
the social biological in some clinical
Sciences where they are often too many
uncontrollable variables but now the
size and complexity and cost of modern
research projects may
even less likely that results can be
reproduced even in fields where it is
traditional and possible in addition the
vast expansion in the amount of research
carried out has been accompanied by an
explosion in scientific publications and
as a result much of what what is
published goes unchallenged I recently
heard of a fairly humorous story of a
checklist of rocky an article which is
published in 1887 and the title of the
article in check is Oh applaud vici
applaud vici for those of you who speak
Czech I don't
it's literally translated as on
dysentery
well when the title was translated by an
abstract it was translated as a name of
the author who for years was cited as
dr. o o play vici much to his chagrin I
sure well this was a thoughtless error
and one that probably had very little
bad result except for the author but
indifference to errors can also be very
damaging in science errors lead
researches down blind alleys published
errors if not corrected can set back an
entire research community scrupulous
scrupulous attention is especially
important now growing competition for
founds tenure and acclaim increasing
chances of financial conflicts of
interests among researchers and even the
scope of intellectual ferment with
intellectual boundaries breaking down
and new ideas and techniques challenging
traditional paradigms all these
conditions make science and engineering
more vulnerable to false to it under
such circumstances it is essential that
the community of researchers as
individuals and through the institutions
that represent them uphold the highest
standards of integrity universities as
the primary locus of basic research have
a special responsibility in this regard
in cases of alleged wrongdoing they have
a duty to analyze the facts fair
we determine accountability protect the
rights of all involved and see that any
falsehood is corrected like Caesar's
wife universities must be above reproach
and all conduct relating to research and
as the cost of that the academic
research enterprises increase so does
the university's dependence upon federal
support and as the federal investment
grows so does the public scrutiny of the
enterprise
so misconduct of any sort imperils
public sponsorship of the research
activity it is a high tribute after
having said all this it is a high
tribute to the integrity of our research
enterprise that all who have
investigated the incident of incidents
of scientific misconduct in fact find
very few cases of bonafide it fraud
errors there are of course and errors
are inevitable because we all as
researchers live in a world of
uncertainty
well how then can the young researcher
and scholar prepare for life in such an
environment where neither the certain
Gaytan guidance of a close mentor is
available nor a firm sense of the rules
of the game there are no easy correct
answers to this question
but there are some guidelines careful
attention to treatment of data choice of
methods and evaluations of on ones own
hypotheses can help guard against the
most common pitfalls mistakes and
self-deceptions there are also some
incorrect behaviors to be avoided
deliberately bypassing the peer review
process researchers who publish in the
popular press risk adverse reactions
later if their results are shown to be
mistaken or misinterpreted by the media
I doubt very much that cold fusion
research benefited from the fact that
much of his scientific review was
carried out in the mass media the
practice of honorary authorship all
so deserves scrutiny in the Renaissance
ages painters who trained their
apprentice they often trained them by
allowing the apprentices to work on
canvases after which they were completed
that to which the master signed his name
and this tradition gave way over time to
a much fairer recognition of an
individual artists contributions of
course but in some fields today in some
research feels it is traditional still
for the senior researchers name to be
put on all work done by the group well I
suggest that not every tradition is good
and that honorary authorship diffuses
accountability and can lead to
irresponsible research failure to bring
wrongdoing to the attention of those
responsible is also incorrect behavior
any assault on the integrity of science
and engineering damages all researchers
it is obvious that in this environment
the conduct of research is a complex and
demanding task quietly and pursue it the
answer to that habit that I believe is
straightforward the possibility of
observing or understanding what no one
has ever observed or understood before
can be irresistible ever since
Archimedes streaked through the streets
of pre-christian Syracuse shouting
Eureka scientists and researchers have
found in the mummer's of discovery or
innovation one of the most exhilarating
experiences in their lives the process
of research itself is a deeply
satisfying experience putting the pieces
of a puzzle in place and making sense
out of a mystery research results in
knowledge that is as certain and as
reliable as any knowledge we as humans
can discover in science and technology
and other fields of intellectual
endeavor among humanity's greatest
achievements having transformed not only
the material condition of our lives but
also the way we see the world a career
in these areas
offers an opportunity to join the
pantheon of scholars who have changed
the condition of life on hertz and
bought the universe closer to our
doorstep TS Eliot once said and I quote
we shall not cease from exploration and
the end of our exploring will be to
arrive where we started and know the
place for the first time in quote well
we have now arrived where we started you
are surviving and will soon have
survived these commencement exercises
soon you will be certified well-educated
and each of you will become standard
bearer for one of the greatest
institutions of higher learning in the
world I know you will carry out this
responsibilities wisely and with
integrity and whatever career you choose
thank you for allowing me to be part of
this significant occasion thank you
you